this and how do we how do we do this
faster so most people probably return to
education as another form of hacking how
do we get past a certain timeframe of
putting energy into something it's
formal education totally necessary when
it comes to writing can't someone still
be a brilliant screenwriter without
having to be part of an MFA program or
even get a bachelor's in writing the
answer is simple and the answer is
absolutely yes of course they can they
can but that for most of us is choosing
a very difficult and lonely road and
here is why citizen any art form before
anything can be art and appreciated as
something that has reached to the level
of art it is a craft first art is
created by craftspeople who have some
inspiration at one moment in their lives
or 50 moments in their lives when the
craft that they do so well rises to the
level of art but you cannot cut to art
without swimming through crafts without
creating an understanding the craft of
anything Georgianna
Keith I don't know why she came to mind
but then Pablo Picasso okay graphic
artists who take it to the level of true
and pure art both of them in their early
years learned their craft they learn
perception they learned color they're
there you know composition there are
things you have to learn tools that
these artists have and when they are
mastered then they can take it into some
very interesting plea and unexpected
places
but you've still got the tools chess
chess is about an interesting game and
there are untold millions of
possibilities maybe infinite
possibilities there are six pieces in
in a chess game but how to use those six
pieces and multiple combinations and so
on create probably the most fascinating
intricate and mind twisting game ever
invented there are tools and
screenwriting and I would take the
position that if this is what somebody
really wants if this is what they're
going for this if all their gifts lead
them in this direction then they need to
get educated about the tools you can do
that on your own but it you know but
you'll need to read a lot of books and
sometimes I mean there's a lot of great
books on screen hiding out of it you
know don't get me wrong there's a lot of
great books and there are tons and tons
of garbage books on screenwriting - and
if you haven't got you know some
guidance you may be wasting a lot of
time on some of those books but if you
come to an MFA program you are pursuing
a couple of things really and what you
what do you get for your money in August
as well first of all you're going
towards a terminal degree a graduate
terminal degree that qualifies you to
teach tenure-track as a professor at the
college or and/or university level and
that's a major certificate that's a
major thing to have like me I had two
them stashed away in the closet
somewhere when the opportunity came up
decades later okay I'm qualified I'm
prepared you know let's go
so that as a writer it gives you another
door to open another avenue to pursue in
life you are less hindered member I said
you got to have to two pathways to be
pursued at the same time your craft and
art yes but at the same time how to
regularize an income well you're a big
step toward the second path when you
have an MFA just the practicality of the
degree but on the other set set of
accomplishments it's about the tool
the tools you will learn who that never
you never knew existed so many people
who don't get a formal education in it
or degree they still talk of
screenwriting as something that falls
from the sky that I don't want that
stuff you know I don't do plot you know
I look I just read this someplace and it
just made me shake my head somebody
you